first we have breaking news overnight
from Greece a horrific head-on train
crash that killed at least 36 people in
engine injured dozens more officials say
a freight train collided with a
passenger train carrying hundreds of
people and we've just learned that a
station master was arrested after the
crash Holly Williams has more
passenger train was packed with
young people coming home after a holiday
weekend just before midnight they
slammed into a freight train a head-on
collision and then a fire that engulfed
the front carriages
we heard a big bang it was 10
nightmarish seconds said this man as we
were turning over we were being burned
the fire was right and left
rescue teams worked through the night
with headlamps and floodlights scouring
the mangled metal for survivors and
bodies
some passengers were reportedly thrown
through the trains windows on impact
others smashed through the glass to
escape when the sun came up the Carnage
was laid bare Greece's deadliest train
disaster in over 50 years
some survivors made it home today others
never will
for CBS morning's Holly Williams London